and they just announced
black panther what kind of friends yes
sir july 8th 20th oh my god
shout out to ryan coogler shout out to
archie who do we think is gonna uh
i have my own theories we were talking
they should just
give it up to michael b jordan loki i
have been i've heard rumors this is not
official and i haven't heard this many
insiders this is youtube
theory that michael b jordan will be
coming back
and i the theory is that he's going to
take on the mantle or sure he is which
is
because he was like a very endearing
loving like bad guy
people [ __ ] with him even at the end
jordan yeah he's a by the way michael b
jordan the most overrated actor
that [ __ ] can is not a good
actor he's he's
he's a nice looking guy to look at he
plays great characters
but he is not a great it's hard for me
to watch michael jordan act i
i i'm not even gonna lie really i don't
think he's a great actor he's not bad
he's not bad
he's not good i didn't say that i'm
saying he's not bad at all he's kind of
like uh
nah you know what you got to be good to
not be bad at acting
trying to think of a rapper we can think
about that think about rap think about
hip hop right you got to be somewhat
good to not be bad
so if you're saying that michael b
jordan is not bad
then then he has to have some sort of
some sort of skill
yeah he's he's he's um
likeable he's got appeal almost like you
think of the rock
early on early on acting you would watch
the rock movies because the rock was in
them yes
and i think michael b jordan is there
now where he's like such a star
women love him he said something about
the movies the rock was also playing
certain type of role he was like i just
watched
i just watched the new michael b jordan
movie on amazon and that [ __ ] was ass
juice but i watched it because he was in
it
you don't like the movie i thought it
was [ __ ] it's a mid man with lots of
seeds in it
the acting was kind of medium and then
they killed lauren london like off the
rip
i was like damn well i mean for those of
you who haven't watched it
you know shade in that [ __ ] very
little
yeah i was like damn it's kind of quiet
i thought it was cool
but i'm a fan of that i play call of
duty a lot so i like that kind of [ __ ]